to my great shame i sort of succumbed
to the narcissism and the
self-involvement that comes along with
that
you know where you where for a while i'm
ashamed to say i expected people to sort
of
know who i was and to treat me
differently and that
it's just not a it's not a healthy way
to live i mean we look at our culture
and there's so many public figures
who are sort of destroyed by being
public figures
you know it's very i mean it's not just
confusing and sometimes it brings out
the worst parts of our personalities so
i am glad that i
personally have sort of gone past that
we're like you know like
i guess i'm still a public figure but
it's not necessarily how
i think of myself on a day-to-day basis
yeah
yeah you mean you're not passing by the
mirror going
hey legend hey famous guy hey
no i walk by the mirror and i'm like who
invited the old guy into my house
this podcast exists because i
love talking to people and i love going
deep the purpose is
to plant seeds of inspiration we
enter a space of vulnerability and
relatability and what you realize
is that we are so much more alike than
we are different
to quote ramdas we're all just walking
each other home
and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense you're gonna hear
at the very beginning of this episode
um but i'm gonna start it off with the
same kind of intro the legend
moby um we started off by of course
talking about
legend and what that really means in his
perspective but he truly
is and really what comes through in
in in all of this and probably if you've
paid attention to any of his
any of the times that he's done
interviews or talked but in his music
what you
felt is his authenticity his
vulnerability the real
rawness of who he is coming through his
music and his art so we talked about how
that translates into other
aspects of his life it was just a really
really nice conversation
i feel like everyone's gonna come away
from this episode feeling like he's a
friend
there's just a level of relatability
that he brings
to uh to anyone that is
uh resonates and i think uh i think
you're all gonna feel that um
so please uh have a good time relating
to
moby today thanks so much for doing this
this is so cool
i'm like such a big fan and you're just
a legend my friend
uh i mean legend to me that just means
essentially like the moment someone's
called a legend just means that they're
old
in my case it actually does work because
i am actually
old um maybe it's different
in the world of sports because i feel
like people become legendary
in sports when they're really young
you know but like with like for example
in the world of music etc like
the first time i was called quote a
legend and grant it does not happen
that often but the first time i sort of
realized like oh that's synonymous
with you're a middle-aged
guy who's on the verge of actually just
being old
i mean i get what you're saying i think
like maybe you're tapping into
you have i had a race or there was a
game or something like that and there's
like a legendary moment of like that
catch or that win um
but you do that with songs like you do
that with an album you do that with a
song like that's
that's a legendary moment you've had
them
well i
thank you very much i hope that you are
correct i feel like it would be
incredibly immodest for me
to completely agree with you
so i'll just i'll just i i hope
i hope that what you're saying is right
but i feel like i don't have the
objectivity
to agree with you also my mom
raised me to be to at least pretend to
be humble so i'll just
i'll just happily say thank you you know
it's actually an interesting concept
i've been thinking about this
um a little bit more lately whether it's
um becoming famous or
um something like that like you can't
because people say
to me sometimes they'll be like oh
aren't you famous i'm like i don't
i think it i don't i don't think it
works like that like i'm not i don't
just become famous or i'm not famous i'm
only famous if you think i'm famous
so it's like maybe legend is similar in
a sense that you don't sign up you can't
go
sign up to be a legend like you can
become a singer you can become a race
car driver you can't become
famous or you can't become a legend that
has to be in the eye of the beholder
yeah i mean and yeah
absolutely i'm sure that you know
anybody who's a public figure has had
that experience of
in one set of circumstances
you know you're incredibly you know you
go you walk into one room
or a bar or a restaurant and everybody
in that bar and restaurant or party
knows who you are and then you walk next
door and no one knows who you are
and it's actually like the first few
times that happens it can be quite
humbling but it's really healthy
just to remember like the majority of
the people on the planet
kind of largely have no idea who we are
which is
which is exactly how it should be um
you know i think like because i when i i
don't know what your experience was like
when i first
started becoming a public figure
to my great shame i sort of succumbed
to the narcissism and the
self-involvement that comes along with
that
you know where you where for a while i'm
ashamed to say i expected people to sort
of
know who i was and to treat me
differently and that
it's just not a it's not a healthy way
to live i mean we look at our culture
and there's so many public figures
who are sort of destroyed by being
public figures
you know it's very i mean it's not just
confusing and sometimes it brings out
the worst parts of our personalities so
i am glad that i
personally have sort of gone past that
we're like you know like
i guess i'm still a public figure but
it's not necessarily how
i think of myself on a day-to-day basis
yeah
yeah you mean you're not passing by the
mirror going
hey legend hey famous guy hey superstar
no i walked by the mirror and i'm like
who invited the old guy into my house
don't worry as we all age we're all
thinking they're like whoa where'd that
wrinkle come from
i will tell you that i see you as a
legend
you can only speak from your experience
but what was it that led you down that
sort of
path where you're like you expected
people to know who you are you expected
certain things
have you realized what it was or was it
more a matter of just
sort of alchemizing that and processing
and
and and and shifting it well i mean when
i first started making music i never
expected to have a career as a musician
you know when i was you know in my teens
and junior high school and high school i
played in little punk rock bands
and like a good night for us was playing
to 10 people
playing to 15 people you know the first
single i ever released with my punk rock
band in connecticut
we sold 100 copies and we thought
we thought that was pretty great that
meant a hundred people had gone out of
their way to buy our record and i was
like wow
this is this is the pinnacle like it's
not going to get any better than this
so when in the 90s when i started having
more
sort of broader success it was so
unexpected and it just it played to all
of my
and maybe this is very very obvious but
it played all of my
insecurities it played to my my
feel my lack of self-worth my
feelings of inadequacy and somehow i
felt that you know if people were nice
to me you know if people wanted to date
me if people invited me to their parties
it sort of gave me this external
sort of validation and as is often the
case i became way too attached to it
you know because you know i had grown up
you know
my mom and i were on food stamps and
welfare i was you know
a little insecure kid growing up and
then suddenly when you're on the
receiving end of attention
you know especially glamorous attention
it can be really
corrupting you know it's because it's so
it's so attractive
[Music]
you know i feel like for myself and just
the things that i've gone through in
life and especially over the last year
like i've realized just how much
like our parents and childhood has
i mean it's it's really the root of
everything there's it's like
the most complicated giant
box that lives underground in the
subconscious
and just wreaks havoc through patterns
until you recognize it
yeah and it's hard because the patterns
you know who we are and who we were
how we were formed as children
you know we're rarely are we capable of
even recognizing
those patterns because they're so
familiar and it's only you know like
we become adults and we start almost
like encountering
the consequences of those patterns you
know whether it's in relationships
whether
it's with addiction whether it's with
friends what have you
and then suddenly you know whether it's
through therapy whether it's
through self-help sobriety what have you
you know like hopefully we learn enough
about ourselves to sort of
at least identify those old patterns
and work to move past them in so far as
we can you know he's it's certainly
obviously much easier said than done if
it was
easy we would all be healed and it would
be one quick moment and we'd be like oh
yes
yeah i i i i forgive you mom i forgive
you dad
but it's not it's not that easy because
like you said they're just like they're
patterns they're
they're ingrained in us and they're
they're almost like invisible because
there's such patterns and
um yeah i mean life is just such a
journey i mean
such a such a complicated journey
i i it's not and one thing i've one
thing i've been
sort of hopefully learning lately and i
don't know why this is the most
self-evident
thing i could ever say is realizing that
it's a complicated journey
for everyone yeah you know because when
i was growing up i thought like i was
the only confused person
i was the only scared person i was the
only insecure person
you know i was the only person who
really was filled with doubts
and then time passes you realize oh
everybody is
you know it's just unfortunately we live
in a culture where most of us are really
good at pretending otherwise
you know people pretending they're
smarter than they actually are
cooler than they actually are um sexier
than they actually
are like so it is sort of nice
remembering that
every human being on the planet
regardless of
you know how they were born where they
were born like
everybody has their own experience of
the human condition and it's
it's confusing to everybody like was
there a moment where you realized that
that you like
finally like freed yourself from this
self-inflicted burden that you're alone
um
oddly i did i was driving and it
it came just a few years ago you know
the actual for like the
physical realization of this i was
driving from los angeles
down to palm springs um i was playing
coachella and i was driving on the 10
and i'm sure you've spent some time on
the 10.
you know and the 10 between los angeles
and palm springs is gross like it's just
especially like when it's hot and
there's traffic like
it's just it's awful and i was you know
sitting in my car
you know feeling sorry for myself
because the traffic
was terrible and i was you know like
everything outside was ugly and brown
and then i looked around at everybody
else in traffic and i had this
realization i was like oh everyone hates
this
like it's not just me in fact most
people probably hate it
way more than i do because you know like
i was leaving my nice home
to go play at a festival and i was going
to stand on stage in front of 40 or 50
000 people like that's
i'm not look it's clearly like my
circumstances were different than most
other peoples and realizing like okay
if this is unpleasant for me like i'm in
my nice car the air conditioning is
going i'm listening to music and i
am happy just think
how much less happy the people around me
are and it gave me this sense
of just very simple
you know and i hope this doesn't sound
insincere but really simple compassion
just this realization like these you
know
everybody is struggling i certainly
can't take my problems
too seriously you know especially when
people are dealing with problems that
are so much worse and more serious than
mine
that's beautiful perspective what gave
you i mean
you are like you are
a very present self-aware i mean
and vulnerable like vulnerable is what
comes through and every you know
watching you and even in your music i
don't even know what to call your genre
like i don't even know like it's hard to
put a thumb on that exactly what it is
and i think that that's a really special
gift
um and a really special talent that an
artist has to be able to do that because
to me it tells me that
it's flowing through you and it's not um
you're not trying to fit in any kind of
a box and i don't get the feeling like
in your life you
um you know you've you've always kind of
had an
ability to march to the be to your own
drum sorry for the silly pun but
um and but that vulnerability like it's
it's only in
being vulnerable and honest that you can
create music that you
uh is not fitting into a genre or to say
something like you've said where it's
like
i realized i wasn't the greatest singer
so i needed to learn how to do other
things and
um i just is this something that you
taught yourself
or is this just who you are how did you
get to that point
i think it's learning from
other people and you know like for
example
when i was growing up as we were sort of
talking about earlier like you know i
grew up poor
i grew up insecure and i grew up as is
true for most people looking for
something that
gave me a sense of comfort
and connection and
really i sat and found that through
books i found that through
art but i mainly found that through
music
and i found you know a lot of music
that was absolutely not vulnerable
and i loved it you know but i it was the
vulnerable
music you know it was neil young
or joy division or
uh james taylor or you know like the
people who were
really who were willing to be vulnerable
their music was what affected me the
most
and so then i thought okay if i'm
profoundly responding to other people's
vulnerability
the best i can do is to at least try to
be
vulnerable myself or when i say
vulnerable slash
honest you know because as i mean
there's a lot of
art in the world that's completely
dishonest
and not vulnerable and some of it's
great you know like whether it's
a really fun hip hop song or
a fun punk rock song or whatever like
you know there's definitely a place for
like
dishonest not vulnerable music
but it's the really tender vulnerable
honest
music that that i connect with and that
i
try to sort of incorporate into the
music that i make
yeah it comes through and that's why
you're still or
that's why you keep going that's why
your music
made you a legend that's why and i i
think that
so it's something i've been considering
too and this comes in the form of
music it comes in the form of
communication um
even just somebody being with you um
or looking at you but there's like a
frequency that comes through
and so i've wondered if there for me i
feel like there's
a frequent there's there's a message and
then there's a frequency so there's like
the words that come out and the way that
it's presented
and then there's like an inherent
frequency with it
that we don't really we're not aware of
but it's coming through and that's the
stuff that
that's what you're talking about the
vulnerability is a frequency
yeah i guess i mean it's all the
information
that it were affected by but we might
not be obviously
aware of yeah you know i mean there's so
much
information in the world that if we were
capable of even responding to 50
of it we'd lose our minds totally you
know like i mean it's just like they're
just
you think of even like and i don't want
to get too nerdy but like
like the spectrum of light like what we
see as the visual spectrum of light is i
think around
1 of the spectrum of light yeah and so
expand that and that's the same thing
with sound it's the same thing
with just all the data that's flowing
around us
so i think that when we communicate when
we you know like
we're almost like using what you call
like you know that frequency
you know we're using all this
information even if we're not aware of
it you know i guess that's where
intuition
instinct chemistry all these things come
from is sort of like
the un the unseen largely unacknowledged
aspects of expression and communication
how does that trickle down in the rest
of your life vulnerability uh
it's is it it's interesting that that's
the really interesting
that's one of the most challenging
things i think and this is true for
almost anybody is like
sure i can be vulnerable through the
music that i make i can be vulnerable
in interviews i can be vulnerable in
books i can be vulnerable
in social media posts but
the hardest thing is being vulnerable in
the presence of an actual
other human being yeah and that
you know like i'd say that's borderline
impossible
especially for like you know i think men
in general are a lot less accomplished
at being vulnerable in the presence of
other people
you know and it's so like yeah i can
write
songs where i bear my soul but bearing
my soul in the presence of one person
you know a friend a family member
someone i'm dating like
that's that's the hardest part i'm
curious what you
how you feel about it but it feels like
we're entering into a phase where um
the fact that there's even that
awareness
that it's harder for men and it i think
it is
i think there's a primal reason i think
that there's
um a cultural reason uh
i think that there's the masculinity in
general
is um you know is its own thing
and so but i feel like we're in a phase
now where where men are aware of it and
that
is the first step too it's kind of like
saying like hi my name is so-and-so and
i'm uh whatever
do you feel that do you feel like an
opening now like that
you know maybe just maybe you could sit
in front of uh
some someone a friend or a partner or
whatever and
sort of like cry or have a moment
i hope so um i mean it definitely like
if we
if we take a step back it certainly
seems like it's moving in that direction
um and i think part of it is also
recognizing
you know the old classic masculinity
is so ridiculous you know when we see
like tough guys taking themselves
seriously
it's like yeah you don't seem tough you
just seem it seems silly
you know and it just it
it just doesn't make sense anymore you
know maybe it made sense
thousands of years ago when you're like
fighting bears
to protect your family and be able to
like
sleep in your cave but now like
like an example of like tough guys being
ridiculous is like
two macho guys getting in a fight over a
parking space
you know people are willing to punch
each other in the face
for a parking space or like some guy
who's like
super angry because his sports team
didn't win
it's like the sports team's not even in
the town where you live
there's no people on the sports team
you've ever met
that they're all making millions of
dollars whether you whether they win or
lose
why is this guy upset yeah you know and
i'm not
criticizing sports sports are great i'm
just saying like
these expressions of traditional macho
masculinity are just
they're just kind of ridiculous yeah
yeah well you know one of the things
that i love
giving my mentally giving myself this
perspective of
you know because i can fall into the
trap of trying to be perfect or trying
to
do certain things and fitting inside of
my own mental box
and but usually in a line alignment with
sort of perfectionism
or uh something in the in that realm
and when i do that i don't give anyone
else permission
to not be perfect right so it's in the
vulnerability which you do in so many
aspects you give permission to people
to make unique music you give permission
to people
to be honest about their childhood you
give
you know in in our flaws we actually
we're so much more relatable because
like you said
15 minutes ago everybody's going through
crap
and so it's in our vulnerability that
we're now relatable but we also then
give the other person permission
to show us them
yeah yeah without question and the
perfectionism you're talking about um
most of my friends are women
and i see so many women it's
heartbreaking like how crippled they are
by the pursuit of perfectionism
right you know and this this idea that
they can only present themselves
as the most perfectly put together
version of who they are you know if
they're going to
write a song it has to be perfect if
they're going to
you know do anything in public it has to
be perfect
and i'm like yeah you be good
you know like it's it's good to you know
like if you're gonna
make a song make a good song but like
the humanity of expression and
connection is so much more interesting
than
perfection you know i mean i'm sure
we've we've all had that experience
where like
maybe you go on a date and like you're
with someone who is like made this huge
effort to be perfect
and there's nothing to relate to you
know like and you almost
you almost want to pull them aside and
say like just like who are you
really like like like what makes you
cry what are your insecurities what do
you look like with no makeup
what do you know like just like i almost
feel like that would be the perfect
first date is like two people come
together
at their work not their worst their
meanest but like looking their worst
you know maybe don't even bathe for a
couple of days beforehand
and like see the connection you have
there as opposed to like
two perfectly put together people
going to an elegant place and having an
elegant night like there's
that's fun but there's no honesty there
totally yeah there's no
the like so going back to like my
mindset of this sort of like
intention or frequency or energy like
there's no true there's no it's not real
it's in the head and not in the body
and that's something for me that i have
worked on myself is pulling information
from the head down into the body and
embodying it
and so i'm curious because you said like
a song and perfection
and then i think are there times where
you've recorded
and you know yes there's like a perfect
way to and i again i don't record music
but you know there's like
executing something with perfection and
then there's executing something with
perfect vulnerability which is
maybe the voice crackles a little or
maybe something but there's like
something about it
it's kind of like a picture maybe where
you see somebody and they're like
smiling and then you see them like turn
and like catch a moment
like the cop moment has so much more
energy than the posed moment even though
they're both smiling pictures
so similarly with a song it's like you
can you can sing it beautifully
or you can sing it with like a little
bit of like that the the
the cop moment of like the emotion of it
and have you chosen or has that happened
to you where you record something you're
like i don't know there's just something
about that one i know it's not perfect
but let's
that's the that's the that's the one
we're putting in the song well exactly
what you're describing
happened because i work with quite a lot
of singers
and what you're describing used to
happen a lot where like
you know i would be working with a
singer they would do a rough run-through
of a song and be great and then we'd do
the official run through
and it wouldn't be nearly as interesting
and so
lately well for the last like maybe even
10 years what i do is when i work with a
singer
i basically record all of their rough
takes and i tell them i'm like okay we
just i just need to get like microphone
levels let's just run through it a
couple times and like
when we're done and i'll say to them
like okay like i just want to run
through it a few times so you can get
familiar with
it and then i'll say to them and then
we'll do
you know the official version
keeping in mind i'm only recording them
doing the unofficial versions because i
know those are going to be the good ones
and i've actually had singers get mad at
me
because when i'm done recording the
unofficial versions i'll say to them
like okay
we're done and they'll they'll be taken
aback they'll be like but
but what about the perfect version i'm
like no this is great we're fine
and i've had some people actually get
very mad at me because i have
denied them the ability to do something
technically perfect whereas what i want
is
emotionally honest that's so
cool so it's a trick that i do now that
i've given it away i'm
no singer will ever work with me again
you're only going to get the right
singers if someone hears it and they
don't want what you're just saying
that's actually almost better news right
to get more
raw to get you want someone to come into
the studio that's like
ready to bear it right ready to just
like lay it out there
otherwise yeah no it's not cool or the
singers
who are so good i mean there are these
people
who are so accomplished and so good
that their perfectionism
involves vulnerability you know
bono would be an example of that like
there's a reason why
he's one of the most successful singers
of all time is because
he's so good he can actually achieve
perfection
and vulnerability at the same time what
would you
why why do you think that is i think
that he's coming from a
very like a place where he loves what
he's doing he loves
expressing himself and i say this
because we've been friends
for quite a while but he also
technically just has that rare voice
that is
technically perfect you know and like
i guess it's kind of like imagine
like a phenomenon like a martial arts
expert who's been doing it forever who's
the best martial arts person in the
world
they're going to be a lot more
comfortable introducing mistakes into
what they're doing
because they have nothing to prove like
they're so good at it
you know they can mess around a little
bit and try out
imperfect things because they know that
they're
just so good at what they're doing so
then how does this play into
the new album reprise where you took all
the old songs and
you know you've you know reframed them
in new ways which it's so
it sounds so cool um well part of it is
most of the music i've made in my life
i've made just by myself in my studio
with a bunch of equipment
and making this album it was the
complete
opposite of doing that where like it
involved working with orchestras
with tons of different singers with
gospel choirs
um recording people in new york
recording people in la recording people
in hungary recording people in the uk
like this as opposed to just like
usually it's just me by myself this one
little guy in the studio
this was this global process involving
quite literally hundreds of people
and especially working with so many
vocalists
and so many acoustic musicians you know
cellists violinists pianists harpists
brass people like it's all
human like this is without question by
definition the least electronic
record i've ever made there's no there's
no electronic elements on the record
oh right there's one bass line that
actually played with the synthesizer but
apart from that it's
all humans making music
and i think part of what
made me want to do this is that
vulnerability you know it's like
is the imperfection because i love
electronic music
but sometimes electronic music can be a
little too perfect whereas
redoing all of these songs with humans
was by definition an imperfect
process and in some cases like one of my
favorite performances on the record is
from chris christopherson
um because he's i mean we met a while
ago and he's this wonderful human being
but he's
he's lived a life you know like he's
quite a bit older
he's had some health issues and if you
listen to his vocal performance
like the vulnerability in it will make
you
weep like and he's so comfortable with
it
like there's a level of sort of
vulnerable genius
in his vocals like i would say if
someone's gonna listen to the out like
if you're only gonna listen to one thing
from the album listen to chris
christopherson's performance
he's singing with mark lanigan and mark
lanigan has a phenomenal voice
and their voices go really well together
but chris christopher's and the
vulnerability and his performance is
just
phenomenal were you able to be with
these
with all these different people or i
mean you know recording this album it
was during 2020 right
we recorded most of it before the
pandemic kicked in
but then a bunch of people had to be
recorded after
and of course that sometimes means them
recording in their garage with a
microphone
or you know coming to my studio
but i never actually there are a couple
singers i've recorded who i've never
actually met
even though they were at my studio
because we set up a microphone
50 feet away from the control room and
so i'd sort of like
the hoops wave to them but like i've
never actually
shaken their hand or talked to them what
was that like
it's it's a very strange process
you know like um the only thing i can
think of it's like maybe it's like
like dancing with someone where you
never
actually see them or touch them it's
it's it was disconcerting
just imagination i mean we have great
imaginations
the dance is the best dance ever yeah
yeah and also i mean like having someone
well it's tricky because over again over
years and years and years decades of
working with singers
as i mentioned earlier i've developed
some ways
of i mean i guess it's the way a
director would work with an actor
whereas like you work with a singer
they're doing something revealing and
vulnerable
and you have to figure out how to manage
them make them comfortable
and both reassure them and challenge
them
yeah and it's hard to do that
when you can't actually talk to them in
person yeah
yeah right there's this i mean
such an interesting time did you learn a
new technique
i want to say that yes i did but the sad
truth is no
i just i mean the only technique was
maybe to get
people to do things a few more times
than they normally would so i could go
back and edit
later but yeah i'm sad to say
i did not learn anything new
in terms of recording music during the
pandemic like and i really wish i had
something like
unique and insightful to offer but
that's honest that that's great
i i feel mo i mean there's obviously so
many people that
sort of struggled and suffered and you
know then there's the
you know physical you know there's
there's losses on the grand scale but
music like i was just my friend just
yesterday was like hey what's going on i
live in arizona i live in scottsdale
she's like asking for fun things to do
and so i said you know
hiking's really good right now and then
i said but it
sucks that there's no concerts
like it really sucks it's a huge loss
that there
aren't concerts well i was reading
something recently that you know the
last
global pandemic was in 1918
right spanish right yeah and
a lot of i guess historians or
anthropologists think that the roaring
20s
was actually a response to that pandemic
you know that like basically in 1917
1918 1919 1920
apparently like the world was even more
shut down than it is now
really well because just think of it
like they didn't have
phones they didn't have you know like
everything i mean all jobs were
in-person
jobs back then so like when that
pandemic
waned apparently people just went crazy
and that's where the roaring 20s came
from
so i heard someone saying like get ready
because it's about to happen again you
know like once this pandemic
abates or ends i feel like
people are just going to rush to concert
venues to nightclubs to
bars to restaurants to
anything you know like i mean i'm old
and kind of misanthropic and i like
being by myself so
i don't know if i'll be rushing yeah i'm
totally
you're gonna be playing you're gonna be
doing it you're gonna be entertaining us
you're gonna comprise number two yeah
one of my only issues i don't really
like
i love playing live music but i really
don't like touring
mm-hmm because i guess i just i did it
for too many years
and it just got too repetitive so now
like
most of the performing i do well
pre-pandemic was
you know at charity fundraisers friends
parties like i'd much rather
walk down the street with an acoustic
guitar and play some songs
in someone's backyard then go on tour
for six months
i have a nice walking guide walking
walking from la to scottsdale
that would be a little of a bit of a
challenge crossing the desert with my
acoustic guitar i feel like that would
be a good
there's a good movie in that we can meet
at coachella for a little tiny concert
yeah um scottsdale is that in arizona is
that
more towards the north or the south it's
it's really right where phoenix is oh
okay
yeah is there cause i still remember
this has
nothing to do with almost anything we're
talking about but the first tour i
ever did we had two days off after a
show in phoenix
and so a bunch of friends and i rented a
car and drove to the grand canyon
because we'd never been to the grand
canyon
and i remember one of the most
remarkable experiences we left
phoenix and it was this was it was in
february
we left phoenix and it was like 68
degrees
and an hour later i think we went we
drove over
this thing called mount mariah
is that a real thing or am i mis well
you probably drove up to flagstaff
we eventually got to flagstaff but i
just remember like
leaving phoenix going up a mountain and
all of a sudden there's 10 feet of snow
everywhere
yeah yeah so what happens in arizona is
everybody
a lot of times people get a house there
for the summer
in the summer have an extra house
because it's 120 degrees in scottsdale
or phoenix and then they go to flagstaff
area where it's like
eight thousand foot eight to twelve
thousand i mean it goes up to twelve
thousand feet where
uh the top of the mountain is um but
eight about eight thousand feet and it's
twenty plus degrees cooler yeah so yeah
snow too
the west coast because i grew up in
connecticut and new york
and what you're describing that just
doesn't exist anywhere on the east coast
or the midwest and like
when i first came out here i live in la
now yeah
and i realized like oh i live in l.a
it's 72 degrees but if i drive for two
hours i can be in 10 feet of snow
and it's 20 degrees you know that
is just it's still mind-boggling to me i
mean look
it seems like everyone's leaving
california maybe you want to come
to arizona the 120 degree summers
might might be a little hard to
to deal with well i understand that's
okay
um turns out there's plenty of space
everywhere for everyone
um i uh so you have a doc coming out too
i feel like you've been
super busy and um i just love the name
of it movie doc that's fantastic
why'd you decide to do it why did you
decide to do a dot
well it's interesting i i well i hope
it's interesting
and it ties back to what we've been
talking about because as you know there
are a lot
of biopics you know documentaries about
writers artists directors musicians
public figures
and one of the things i think i've
learned over time
is you know that and we
and i apologize for repeating myself but
that
the human condition can't be fixed
with fame it can't be fixed with money
it can't be fixed
with possessions
and so the documentary is largely
i think the goal was to make something
unique and idiosyncratic
that looks at that issue you know like
using me as the
test subject almost like how i tried to
fix
you know so many you know psychological
things
with fame or money or
you know validation or materialism
and not surprisingly it didn't work
so that's the idea behind the
documentary to show that
you know you just can't you can't fix
yourself
with fame and stuff um well you said the
more successful you got
essentially the more alone you felt
right or the
the worse you felt which i think
i mean it's it's funny because we're
still surprised when people have that
experience
but almost everybody has that experience
i mean like just recently there was the
meghan markle interview with oprah
you know she's a princess
hanging out in buckingham palace and
she's despondent and wants to kill
herself
you know like and we're all so surprised
by that but like but yeah that happened
to diana too and
and it happened to kurt cobain and it
happened to ernest hemingway and it
happened to avicii and it happened
to robin williams and on and on and on
like
like
really and i'm not complaining or
looking for sympathy
but as you probably know firsthand like
fame should come with a warning label
like
just beware like you think fame is going
to fix
things but boy oh boy it just doesn't
um i love like i think maybe it's jim
carr i'm sure
plenty of people kind of said this very
sort of thing but jim carrey like i wish
everyone could get rich and famous so
they could realize that it's not
like that's not the be all end-all like
that's not gonna fix anything
i mean they're nice obviously and i
apologize again for stating the obvious
but there are nice aspects it's nice to
be able to pay the rent
it's nice to be able to see the world
it's nice to have recognition
for what you love to do but
boy oh boy whenever anyone
expects fame and attention
to fix their innermost issues
uh i mean just history is just littered
with people for whom
you know the process of getting fame has
cut their life expectancy by about 80
you know sometimes there are like
reports on work
safety yeah and they'll say like well
the most dangerous job in the world
is being an alaskan fisherman and in
terms of life expectancy
the most dangerous job in the world is
being a public figure it is
true the public figures have their
shortest life expectancy
you know think like amy winehouse if
she'd never become famous
she probably would live to be 70. kurt
cobain without saying he'd probably
still be a lot
jimi hendrix jim morrison janice joplin
john lennon on and i mean avicii
porovici died in his
killed himself in his 20s you know like
so
so what's the catch like what's the what
is what's what's the safety net or
what's the what's the rope that's going
to pull you back in because
you know we're looking at it on a really
magnified scale or a public scale of
being famous and it kind of exacerbates
things
but i think that there's a there's a
correlation between
that and everything else so there must
be
the rope that you can hang on to to pull
you out of the [ __ ] and
what is that that's a great question
i i have to think that maybe it's maybe
it's different
for different people you know like some
people like i'm grateful for the fact
that i bottomed out completely you know
like before i got sober 12 years ago
like i was
suicidal depressed anxious
despondent and i'm grateful for it
because it forced me
to do the work to try and get better you
know if i had never bottomed out that
way
i never would have been compelled to do
the work
but for other people they don't need to
bottom out you know other people it's
just simply having a great
you know being being smart having a
great education
um not having an addictive personality
uh having a good family structure good
friend structure
you know like not everybody needs to get
to the place that i got to of like this
you know suicidal dark knight of the
soul
so i guess different people are saved by
different things and very sadly
some people simply aren't saved
i think we all i think we're all
destined to go through our own semi-dark
night of the soul i
can attest to that but um your
sharing of it gives us all permission so
um i just want to say thank you
i just don't say thank you for your
music your art your vulnerability
your relatability then and um
you know uh i'm i'm a big fan and um
to to to come full circle it's been nice
to talk to a legend so thank you so much
well i still take issue with the legend
aspect but everything else thank you
very much this has been wonderful it's
like
you know obviously you and i both we
talk to a lot of people
um but it's one wonderful thing
about modern life is you can have a
conversation with someone you've never
actually spoken to
and have a really you know
personal intimate great
conversation so thank you for that yeah
you're so welcome and thank you from for
doing it it's been
my honor my pleasure my pleasure
congrats on everything
oh thanks well i mean actually what i'm
most excited about is
it it rained last night but the sun just
came out so i'm gonna head out and go
hiking now
yeah i love that and i don't ever get a
chance to talk to you about
animals and veganism and agriculture and
everything like that but
um thanks for all of that as well oh
yeah well next time hopefully we can
have a
conversation only about animal
agriculture and
veganism love to thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more please click on the subscribe
button